je vous propose si vous voulez bien de
commencer cette conférence en
reproduisant partiellement une étude
américaine et j'aurai besoin de tous les
hommes ici présents comme cobayes salé
comme andy cobayes en anglais guinée pig
qui se traduit par cochons d'inde
ces jolis collants même donc messieurs
les cochons d'inde
imaginez que vous êtes célibataire ou
que votre femme n'est absolument pas
jalouse et imaginer que l'une de ses
deux charmantes soeurs se propose de
vous faire réviser les positions du
kamasutra
alors il faut en choisir une je vous
rappelle que vous êtes des cochons
d'inde n'est pas des cochons
donc s'il vous plaît qui choisirez
celles de droite lever la main s'il vous
plaît dites lever la main on peut être à
lui un petit peu les lumières pour voir
ouais c'est pas mal d'accord
et maintenant qu'ils préféraient révisée
avec la demoiselle à votre droite
pardon emprunt gauche droite donc bien
celles en bleu y en a un peu moins
donc vous êtes exactement deux tiers
selon le professeur elio de l'université
de rochester a préféré la jeune fille en
rouge si je vous avais présenté cette
photo vous auriez été également deux
tiers a préféré la jeune fille en bouche
pourquoi et bien mesdames sachez que
naturellement quand vous portez du rouge
vous éveiller en nous un désir un désir
très fort 25% de désir en plus pour les
hommes
et sachez mesdames que vous en avez
conscience ou alors c'est inconscient
mais vous le savez une étude portait sur
les sites de rencontre où on a regardé
comment la couleur des vêtements des
femmes sur leur photo de profil les
femmes qui recherchent le grand amour
sont cinq fois moins souvent habillés en
rouge que celles qui recherchent le
grand frisson
et oui le rouge est une couleur
défis créés le désir chez l'homme sachez
que vous aurez 25% de pourboire en plus
ce restaurant quand vous êtes habillé en
rouge
sachez que les hommes s'arrêteront
beaucoup plus souvent quand vous faites
de l'auto stop quand vous êtes habillé
en rouge
pourquoi et bien mesdames sachez que
quand vous portez du rouge
en fait vous indiquer aux sommes que
vous êtes en période d'ovulation
et oui notre très très lointaine grand
mère lucie en période d'ovulation avait
les lèvres génitales et labiales qui
était rouge pour indiquer à son fiancé
que c'était pas le moment d'aller
chasser le mammouth qu'il fallait rester
par là donc le rouge fait de vous des
femmes beaucoup plus sexy
qu'en est il des hommes pas sûr non on
n'est pas plus sexy en rouge
non non mademoiselle on n'est pas plus
sexy en rouge par contre on est beaucoup
plus fort notre rythme cardiaque est
plus élevé notre pression artérielle est
plus forte
notre nombre de battements de paupières
est plus élevé également le rouge nous
rend plus fort quelques preuves dans le
sport en angleterre il ya trois équipes
habillé en rouge
arsenal liverpool et manchester elles
ont gagné 39 des 69 dernier championnat
depuis la guerre en lutte gréco romaine
depuis 1896 et le début des jeux
olympiques modernes
sachez que 67% des combats ont été
gagnés par les lutteurs habillé en rouge
même type de résultat en taekwondo
quand vous portez du rouge vous êtes
physiquement plus fort votre adversaire
vous sent plus fort même larbitre en
conditions égales vous sent plus fort
quand vous êtes en bouche d'un point de
vue pratique s'habiller en rouge fait de
vous un leader et si par hasard l'un
d'entre vous était lui plus tard
président des états unis d'amérique
ses conseillers en communication lui
proposeront le jour de son investiture
d'arrivée avec sa famille habillée comme
ça ce n'est pas du tout un hasard
voilà une famille de leader voilà une
famille en qui on a confiance
le rouge à d'autres qualités le rouge
vous permet d'avoir chaud quand on dit
que c'est une couleur chaude
c'est une réalité vous allez surestimé
la température ambiante de 2 degrés ce
qui fait que en haut de l'everest les
défilés la mode est toujours au rouge
depuis une quarantaine d'années et ils
ont raison
vous mettrez deux fois plus de glaçons
dans un coca que dans un pepsi
parce que justement le coca vous paraît
plus chaud la couleur a aussi un autre
avantage dans le marketing c'est qu'elle
vous permet de reconnaître les marques
vous avez reconnu exactement un dixième
de seconde
coca cola et pepsi sur cette image je
vous aurais présenter cette image vous
auriez été perdu 80% de la
reconnaissance d'une marque c'est sa
couleur
donc vous comprenez que dans le
marketing quand on travaille les marques
la couleur est absolument fondamentale
je vais vous donner un exemple à 200
millions de dollars sur l'importance de
la couleur en 2012 google s'est demandé
si le bleu de ses liens commerciaux que
l'on voir leur équipement grisé pouvait
avoir une incidence sur le nombre de
clics
donc tous autant que nous sommes en 2013
nous avons testé 50 nuance de gris de
bleu à les deux bleus bien peu grisé et
il s'avère que il se regarde dans le
monde entier et ils ont déterminé le
bleu qui nous aider le plus à cliquer ça
se joue quelques chiffres après la
virgule est ce qu'il est un peu plus
foncé un peu plus clair un peu plus vers
un peu plus à l'est toujours est il que
d'avoir changé le bleu cette personne
qui est le patron de google angleterre a
estimé que le gain du changement de bleu
était de 200 millions de dollars rien
que d'avoir changé la couleur du lien
commercial
les recherches sur l'importance de la
couleur sur nos produits date des années
50 avec procter and gamble tu es
certainement l'une des marques les plus
investis dans le marketing
et qui s'est demandé si dans ces
lessives qui à l'époque était blanche
le simple fait d'ajouter des paillettes
de couleur pouvait avoir une incidence
des ménagères ont testé la même lessive
mais avec des paillettes soie rouge soit
jaune il soit bleu elles sont revenues
deux mois après en donner leurs
résultats au delà des espérances des
chercheurs parce que première conclusion
aucune ménagères ne s'est rendu compte
qu'elle testé trois fois la même lessive
tout en vue de la différence une grande
majorité d'entre elles ont estimé que la
lé sida et les paillettes jaune n'était
pas assez efficace n'avait pas bien le
linge à l'opposé la lessive avec des
paillettes rouges était très puissante
peut-être même trop et à l'abîmé le
linge ce qui fait que certaines
ménagères n'ont pas osé finir leurs
barils de lessive avec des paillettes
rouges là les cils avec des paillettes
bleues par contre était une lessive
formidable non seulement elle respectait
le linge elle avait bien mais surprise
elle sentait bon le frais et oui le
simple fait de mettre des paillettes
bleues dans de la lessive dans
l'impression que le linge est plus frais
et 100 meilleurs quelques années plus
tard le vert a obtenu les mêmes
résultats que le bleu et voilà pourquoi
depuis depuis les années 50
toutes les lessives ont dû rouge pour
signaler leur efficacité du bleu et du
vert pour signaler le respect du linge
et la fraîcheur et oui nous sentons
avant tout avec nos yeux tous autant que
nous sommes et même les professionnels
je vais vous donner un exemple
l'université de bordeaux
54 de nos log on testé un aoc bordeaux
blanc il connaissait forcément parker
avec un colorant rouge inodore sur les
54 nos loeb
devinez combien se sont fait avoir 54
ils ont tous trouvé des arômes de fraise
de tuer etc bref les attributs de vin
rouge le même vin présenté quelques
temps plus tard sans colorant avait
subitement des notes citronnées
de beurre blanc et c'est donc des
attributs de vin blanc
si on se fait avoir sur notre odorat on
se fait aussi fortement influencé sur
notre pari sachez que nous goûtons
également avant tout avec les yeux tous
les grands cuisiniers du monde travaille
énormément la couleur autant que la
recette c'est une finale 7 est belle le
plat sera meilleur c'est une réalité une
expérience amusante qu'il prouve a été
menée par heinz qui voulait savoir
quelle était la bonne couleur pour un
ketchup épicé ils se sont rendus compte
que tous les consommateurs avaient le
sentiment que plusieurs ketchup et est
foncée plus ils étaient épices et le
même ketchup et certaines personnes qui
avaient le sentiment de ne pas aimer le
catch up trop épicé 10 et celui-là je
suis incapable de le manger il est trop
fort par contre les rouges claire savard
et inversement ceux qui aiment et
ketchup très épicé 10 et les rouges
clair c'est pas pour moi je préfère cela
qu'est par une bien meilleure donc nous
sommes vraiment fondamentalement
influencé par la couleur chaque couleur
à son influence une étude intéressante a
été menée en angleterre on a demandé à
des adultes de jouer aux lego
les instructions étaient simples s'était
fait du jamais vu
des groupes ont eu cette instruction en
bleu et d'autres l'ont eue en rouge les
groupes dans l'instruction en bleu sont
partis dans leur hémisphère droit de
leur cerveau et ont commencé à faire des
objets créatifs des oeuvres d'art qui
voulait rien dire
ceux qui ont eu la même instruction
écrite sur un panneau rouge sont partis
dans leur cerveau cartésien et on fait
des objets fonctionnels une nouvelle
maison une nouvelle voiture une nouvelle
une nouvelle robe et c'est donc le
simple fait de donner une information
d'une couleur influence la façon dont
nous la percevons vous êtes tous autant
que vous êtes beaucoup plus créatif dans
un environnement bleus vos idées seront
plus pertinente
vous aurez des idées beaucoup plus
original beaucoup plus nouvelle est
beaucoup plus d'idées ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui quand on fait on est en
prennent storming on le sait on vous met
dans des environnements chromatique
bleus pour vous aider à trouver des
idées
par contre si on veut attirer votre
attention que vous restiez concentré on
privilégiera les ambiances chromatiques
chaude c'est à dire jaune orange ou
rouge
alors quand on dîne ambiances
chromatiques chaude on n'est pas obligé
d'avoir les pièces entièrement rouge une
pièce comme celle là par exemple qui est
majoritairement blanche nous apparaît
rouge parce que il ya des détails de
rouge là dedans dans ce genre de bureau
la productivité excellente
vous êtes capable de travailler des
heures et des heures sans vous fatiguer
parce que justement l'énergie du rouge
va vous aider malheureusement
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'entre nous
travaillons là dedans c'est 10 % de
productivité en moins c'est 15% ne
risque de burn out
en plus les ambiances à chromatique qui
existent en occident depuis une
vingtaine d'années sont on va dire pas
terrible pour rester poli je vous
conseillerais plutôt de mettre du rose
parce que l'heureuse va vous aider le
côté autorisant du rose quand on dit
voir la vie en rose
il s'appuie sur une réalité en
angleterre on a repeint des salles de
classes de maternelle qui était belge en
rose et on a comparé les dessins des
enfants sur 10 ans les dessins avant que
les salles de classe soir aux pattes et
après de façon significative les dessins
des enfants sont beaucoup plus positif
vous avez des sourires beaucoup plus
marquée de plus gros soleil le rose est
une couleur euphorisantes et relaxante
des chercheurs en ont cherché un usage
nous sommes à seattle dans une prison
quartier de haute sécurité
sachez que dans cette prison les détenus
les plus énervés quand on les plonger
dans cette prison contre les lycées ne
serait-ce qu'un quart d'heure il
devenait calme comme des agneaux les
mauvaises langues disent que c'est parce
qu'ils aimaient tellement pas cette
couleur qui n'osaient plus bouger
toujours est il que mettre des détenus
là dedans ça fonctionne personnellement
je j'ai équipé d des cellules de crise
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques avec du
rose et pour la petite histoire le
tapissier qui pensaient faire son
travail en trois jours a mis cinq jours
travaillés dans une tente du rose très
fort comme ça ils n'arrivaient pas à
travailler et le résultat à l'arrivée
même pas terrible
il ya des plis par tous voilà donc le
rose est une couleur euphorisante
mais je vous inviterai plutôt à dormir
dans des chambres mov et oui sachez que
dans une chambre comme celle là vous
avez en moyenne 3 5 rapports sexuels par
semaine
c'est une étude anglaise sur 2000 couple
qui nous apprend ce résultat il sachets
que 3,5 rapport par semaine ça fait tous
rapports par mois et que des chercheurs
actuellement des médecins disent que
douze rapports par mois ces dix ans
d'espérance de vie en plus donc si vous
le faites pas pour vous faites-le par
altruisme pour votre partenaire
c'est important de penser à l'espérance
de vie de votre partenaire et voilà dans
quoi on vit sans parler des dix ans
ondine ambiances chromatiques comme ça
vous êtes à moins de deux rapports par
semaine c'est vous qui voyez
cette image me fait me fait très peur
parce qu en fait j'étais sur google la
semaine dernière et j'ai tapé le mot
chambre et design c'est la première
photo sur google qui apparaît c'est à
dire que nos tendances actuellement en
occident nous pousse à aller vers ça
nous pousse à aller là où il n'y a pas
de couleur
aujourd'hui trois voitures sur quatre
sont grises noires ou blanches dans les
années 50 75 % des voitures étaient
colorés avec un trio gagnant le vert le
bleu île rouge
ceux qui ont eu la chance d'aller à cuba
le vois très bien voilà comment nous
vivions il n'y a pas si longtemps il n'y
a pas si longtemps on n'imaginait pas
construire une bibliothèque
autrement que verte pourquoi vert parce
que quand vous lisez un livre vous
activer à la fois votre cerveau créatif
pour arriver à interpréter ce que dit
l'auteur mais en même temps votre
cerveau rationnel pour rester concentrés
dans l'histoire le vert est la meilleure
couleur pour la lecture voilà pourquoi
vous êtes aussi nombreux à aimer lire
sur des bancs publics
le vert est une excellente couleurs mais
aujourd'hui combien de bibliothèques
sont encore avec develop vert idem pour
les salles de spectacle on n'imaginait
pas il ya encore vingt ans contre les
salles de spectacle autrement que rouge
pourquoi parce que vous êtes concentré
parce que les personnes sur scène au
théâtre ont le sentiment que le public
est beaucoup plus chaleureux donc la
symbiose se passe mieux
c'est la bonne couleur aujourd'hui des
cinémas malheureusement sont souvent
comme ça le même film dans ce cinéma
risquent de vous paraître ennuyeux alors
que vous pouvez le trouver absolument
formidable dans un environnement
chromatique rouge nous sommes 20 % en
france à prendre régulièrement ou très
régulièrement des antidépresseurs je ne
dis pas que la couleur fait tout mais
quand on voit à quel point ça fait
plaisir de recevoir un bouquet de fleurs
c'est à dire de recevoir la couleur
j'aimerais que vous posez tous la
question comment serait notre moral si
nous suivions avec plaisir la mode
indienne et que nous étions tous
habillés comme ça
comment serait notre moral si nous
vivions dans des villes comme ça qu'ils
recherchent la couleur partout pierre
dac à une réponse que j'aime beaucoup
c'est si la matière grise était plus
rose le monde vraiment les idées noires
merci